أه من حيث الحجم الأعداد أه
لقد وضعناهم في حوالي
20000 أم أنت تعلم أنها تحتل أه إما
كليًا أو جزئيًا عنك تعرف 10
10 قواعد على الأراضي الليبية أم
انظر الخمسة زائد خمسة اللجنة العسكرية المشتركة
تجتمع بالفعل  مرة أخرى
اليوم في سوريا إنها جولتهم السابعة
أه هم
أه ذاهبون إلى أه حقًا المضي قدمًا
أتوقع أن يتم تنفيذ أم افتتاح
الطريق الساحلي بين أبو
غرين وسرت وهذا ما تعلمون
لتمكين أه التدفق الحر لـ  الناس
والبضائع أه بين شرق
ليبيا وغربها
، يبدو الأمر صعبًا ، لكن
الرسائل البسيطة التي
قالها الليبيون ، استمع إلى
الليبيين الذين أوضحوا
أنهم حددوا ساعة مدتها 90 يومًا ، لقد كان طموحًا
لا يصنع  إنه طلب أقل
شرعية كما تعلمون
أو أي طلب أقل إلزامًا
بصراحة
على الدول
أو المنظمات التي جلبت
أه
المرتزقة إلى ليبيا.